when you ask how do you save your first
hundred thousand that's how you do it
you live below your means and my plan
was always to save enough so i could
take the risk to bet on myself you've
had all these people on your show what
are the common traits that you keep
seeing over and over and over and over
and over again every single person
shares the same exact qualities they've
all had
huge challenges
and one of the messages we got to push
through them no matter what what do you
have to lose
nothing
and there he is mr randy kaplan how you
doing man helen how are you my friend
i'm great so guys if you don't know
randy he is a super successful
entrepreneur he's built a business with
billions with a b and revenue he's a
venture capitalist and he's also a host
of his own show called in search of
excellence and uh the first video i saw
of him he was talking about how he
thinks the most powerful four words in
the english language are i believe and
you and so uh that's already a win for
me randy welcome aboard man
thanks for having me i love your show
it's true honor
cool so
i think a lot of the people watching
would look at someone like you and say
holy cow that's impossible like how do i
reach that level a lot of people are
still in the early stages of building up
their business
how does somebody go from
their idea to even just making the first
100k in their business
well let's back up for a second because
anything is possible that's one of my
mottos and if you look at my own career
i grew up with not a lot single mom and
when i came to la i lost my job i had
three thousand dollars in the bank and
twelve hundred dollars in rent so my
career like all successful people i know
has a lot of ups and downs we have to
pursue and
plow through our challenges
so you look at my career and it was step
by step so you asked the question how
did someone save the first hundred
thousand i was a lawyer i made seventy
two thousand a year i live way below my
mains i drove a very old car
and i saved on the seventy thousand
anatomy around 50 000 so at the end of
the day i saved a bunch of money i bet
on myself
and each year i was always saved twenty
thousand dollars and then when i changed
my career to an investment banker
working at south america they saved
around 35 000 so when you ask how do you
save your first hundred thousand that's
how you do it you live below your means
and my plan was always to save enough so
i could take the risk to bet on myself
and ultimately when we started our tech
company i'd say four hundred thousand
dollars at age 29 my annual nut was 40
000 a year so i figured i had 10
years to make something of myself i was
living next to the jack-in-the-box it
wasn't the nicest place in the world but
i was determined to work hard and and do
well that's a lot of discipline like
most people really really really really
really struggle with that as soon as you
start making a little bit of money you
start spending it right away you buy the
nicer house or the nicer car the nicer
clothes or whatever the thing
is to maintain that discipline is it
just thinking about
hey i want to start this business and
i've got this goal and i need to have
this amount saved and that's what you're
focused on
it was more of a i always knew the
mindset i knew i'd read books about
every cup of
coffee at
starbucks was four dollars then and
people were spending 100 a week on
coffee and i was very careful on how
much i spent
uh this is actually funny i eat pizza
four times a week there's a pizza place
not very far from me i forget the guy's
name and it was a three second phone
call hey
ed randy same thing same thing click and
the piece would come 20 minutes later i
think the pizza was twelve dollars it
came with two so that would carry me
through the week i really watched what i
ate i watched my expenses it wasn't the
healthiest thing but i knew i had a plan
and my plan was ultimately
i would work at a law firm then go to
work for a company and then after that
company i would hopefully go work for a
client at the age of 30 and eventually
start my own business but my career got
off to the worst start possible and so i
i changed plans saying i don't like
being a lawyer i got i really have to
change things up and change my life
wrong because i was miserable what i was
doing i wasn't good at it and it wasn't
going well but i was very very focused
on saving money and ultimately went to
work for a public company the stock did
well i was able to cash out my options
so by the time i was 30 i had 400 000
saved in my own money
what was the key thing for you to
develop that mindset you know a lot of
people look at you and say i'm in
similar situation like i didn't have the
best upbringing or i've got a single mom
or you know i didn't have the best
mentors around me was it was it books
was it probably not youtube at the time
but yeah how were you
you know how did you develop that
mindset when it probably wasn't around
your immediate circle
you know just not having uh a lot of
money when i was younger my mom was a
single mom working two jobs when i was
much younger than she married someone
she didn't love to take us kind of to a
middle class uh
neighborhood i saw a lot of my parents
friends working very very hard
i grew up in detroit there are a lot of
people there who did very well
financially but no one knew it they
lived very modestly so when i started
looking around and saying okay that
person's worth this or have a home like
that but they drive a buick i thought
you know that's interesting how do i
really think about that and i knew i had
a plan and i did read some books when i
was in uh college tony robbins i read a
book uh my my freshman year in college
that uh that was phenomenal unlimited
power and it really changed my life it
changed my mindset that was kind of all
mixed in to me wanting to budget and me
wanting to take a risk on myself one day
i had a t-shirt business in uh college i
went door-to-door selling t-shirts i
made good money
and it was a lot of fun i learned a lot
of cold calling skills but i saved money
and i allowed myself to go and to get uh
things i wanted in uh college i remember
i really liked this girl in college
wendy wiese and it took me six months
for her to say i'll go out with you and
at the end of the day i took her little
caesar's pizza kitchen we sat at the
counter
it was
it was what i had money for
and you could tell she wasn't very happy
and that was the only time that i went
out with her but but that i i was always
true to myself i never tried to live
beyond my means i didn't need to get a
bmw when i came right out of law school
could have but again you keep asking i
was very focused i knew my plan
i knew i wanted to bet on myself and and
really
save money so i could do it i mean as a
lawyer you're working very long hours
you know 70 hours a week minimum at sun
america i worked way more than that 90
some weeks
and so while i was there i just had my
head down i still socialized i still had
fun and you can do all those things and
just be very cautious on how you spend
money
did you get to the point where you felt
that that ended up
maybe being a handicap for your future
growth and and just sharing a little
about my story i i mean i struggled as
well i mean eating the same bean salad
lunch every day
uh but i i think honestly where i'm at
right now maybe for the past number of
years i should probably be investing
more and spending more for growth but
i'm i've still got the
not the broke mentality but the like i
gotta save i gotta watch every single
penny and i think it i think it's
honestly limiting my growth and where i
can go and as someone who's you know
built businesses with billions in sales
and venture capital all that
has that did you have to switch that
mindset of dollars it's still in you you
know it's still there i mean i remember
thinking um
whenever i one of my goals was i want to
go into barney's one day and buy a suit
not on sale because i've always waited
for the sale it's 70 off so the company
goes public and the stock is worth
a lot of money and i'm worth a lot of
money on paper so i walk into barney's i
was with my wife at the time uh step
brother and his wife i'm sitting there
it took me 45 minutes i was 1700 for the
suit i got my goal could not pull the
trigger i bought one or two suits and
and so
it sticks with you on the personal side
on the business side that's a great
question because
as a founder of a company you really
want to control the cash you see all
these companies today they're raising 10
million dollars 30 million
uh dollar rounds now some of these seed
rounds are insane
and they hire tons of people right out
of the gate well
i wouldn't know if i hired if i raised
10 million right now for my company on
sandy what i would do with that money
we're going to raise money at the end of
the year
um
i don't know how much 2 million 3
million 500 000 i'm going to be very
careful we don't want to spend money
that we don't need to spend we create a
business plan we look at what the costs
are going to be the employee costs the
uh
medical benefits rent
uh all kinds of other things but but
we're not going to spend more than we
need so i am careful what's interesting
is i was a lawyer
and you're trained to be careful you're
trained to be proactive as the founder
of a company you're trying to go for it
so you're trying to you know you're
going to pull the you know you're going
to just put the pedal into the metal and
it's that balance as well that kind of
helps me um i have the instinct i have
the drive i'm cautious and i'm cost
conscious so it's really a mix of those
three things that helps me decide how to
run companies that i'm running
you launched a show in search of
excellence and and there seems to be
this
drive inside you to not just
build companies but also to share and
give back and the lessons you've learned
to try to contribute to other
entrepreneurs as well
uh you know is that true and where does
that come from
yeah um
i've always had a desire to give back
and
i've done so even before i made money i
created a nonprofit called the justice
ball it's a charity function for
basically a non-profit law firm in los
angeles it helps 12 000 people a year
get free
legal aid
i've been very fortunate in my career
and when i had nothing i read
stories and books about successful
people and it really motivated me i
learned from these books
and as i got older i had the opportunity
to work with some great people i still
kept reading i could see people um talk
and i would always be inspired by the
lessons they were teaching the stories
how they got there and really inspiring
to hear the challenges and how they
persevered through the challenges which
is really important for us on our path
to greatness
i've had a
intern program in my firm i'm jump
invested now for 17 years we hire now 36
kids for summer we got about a thousand
applications right now and one of my
great joys is mentoring them teaching
them lessons i spend 60 to 90 minutes a
day with them going through my career
lessons about venture capital private
equity real estate the intangibles which
are often more important than the
tangibles and it's really made a huge
difference in the lives of these interns
where they can hear the stories that
i've had i really focus more on the
negatives and the mistakes i've made
because you learn more from your
mistakes i think than your wins
a lot of the times but it's really i get
noticed from them that it's changed
their lives and i'm i'm very blessed now
where i can call the ceo of goldman
sachs and say this is a great um intern
he'll do well there she'll do well there
and it's just so
satisfying for me
and so the interns have been saying for
years and and one other uh part of our
program we have
speakers come in
once a week these are friends of mine
they do as a favor successful founders
venture capitalist private equity
founders you know every name that's
there they do it as a favor to me and
the guest speaker programs have been one
of the hallmarks of our program
and i've done some public speaking at
schools a whole bunch of them and i get
the crowd of people when i'm done
and usually 20 or 30 people here's a
card i love helping them i love
mentoring them
so
i thankfully have the relationships now
where i can
access or call up or friends of friends
who know people
to have some of the most successful
people in the world on my podcast i've
had sharon stone sam zell sammy hager
orlando bravo tim draper deepak chopra
is doing my podcast
um ed milette is doing my podcast
and and
my goal is to inspire and motivate
others
to be the best they can be to overcome
all of our challenges and ultimately
ultimately my goal is to make a
difference in these people's lives i
love it and the show again it's called
in search of excellence for the youtube
audience we'll link that up in the
description you know check it out um
chris voss has been on kevin o'leary has
been on and mark cuban's been on and
lots of great entrepreneurs
for the mentoring sessions that you do
have you thought of filming those and
creating content around that we um
i have and we're going to do it in a
more professional
uh
setting in uh the future i'm usually
walking around the room with my interns
there's 36 of them there the space isn't
very nice
so but i will be doing that in in the
future in some way shape or form maybe
in a format like this instagram live um
we're thinking about it for the upcoming
summer we have our first group of
interns coming i think next week we have
11
starting next week we have a whole plan
for the summer i'm super excited uh
about our program this summer but the
answer is yes i want to do it and we're
going to do it at some point
i think it's honestly one of the biggest
opportunities for you and it's
it's my great passion to get people like
you who've had a lot of success and get
that message out to the world
uh and there's a lot of interview shows
which is awesome and and should continue
but i think the seeing the mentoring
happen like do you people be able to see
them themselves in the people that
you're bringing on yeah and see how you
work
you know even professional or not just
seeing you helping people i think people
will resonate with um and depending on
where you want to build the brand but um
yeah mentoring and coaching videos i
think is a huge huge opportunity for
someone like you who's actually good at
it and has tons of you know experience
thank you i'll uh
take the feedback my podcast is a little
different format they go uh 90 minutes
but they're very thorough in the
research not that people aren't but
every guest has said i'm the most
prepared questioner they've ever had
every person proactively david
rubinstein mayor garcetti said that uh
and he's he's been
interviewed ten 000 times in his career
but every single one has proactively
said that so
if you do tune in i'd love you to and
you're gonna learn snippets up about
people's careers and lives you've never
heard before one of the things one of
the hallmarks of my success has been
one doing people that people haven't
done before and part of that is what i
call extreme preparation so people will
come in for a
job interview they'll sit there
maybe read my linkedin my website that's
it i prepare for my podcast
25 hours per podcast i do all the
research i do all the writing
that's why i've had every great
opportunity i've had in my career i've
created and i've done it my goal is to
walk into the room and be the most
prepared person every single time i do
it and it's working and that's one of
the things that i teach and it's one of
the things that people
don't do and you're going to be hearing
a lot more
from me about extreme preparation in the
future
i love it and it's a great strategy not
just for making a podcast but for
running your business and making
connections
no doubt and i tell that to the interns
who are 18 to 20 years old when they go
in for the interviews when they go in
for a job later i get emails
10 20 years from former people have gone
through the program they're up for a job
they get the job randy this is
phenomenal the lessons on extreme
preparation and some of the intangibles
that you taught me have made a
difference but really we're talking
about preparing in a way that
point zero one percent of the people do
and i want to bring that message to them
to the masses
extreme preparation sounds like a pretty
good book title too randy um
it may in fact be
stay tuned for the end of the year
that's what i'm gonna say about that
all right i like it i like it we'll do a
round two um so you've had all these
people on your show and you've hung
around lovely super successful people
who who haven't been on the show as well
and maybe future guests yeah what are
the common traits that you keep seeing
over and over and over and over and over
again well it's sort of like how you
begin the beginning of this uh talk
today
people look at
those who are very successful samzell
all these fortune
400 people sharon stone
actresses they all put our pants on the
same way you and i do they started out
with nothing every single one of them
they've had massive setbacks
a lot of these people have gone bankrupt
and the message is you know we start
with our family on my on my uh podcast
we want to know what people were like as
a kid what their family was then we talk
about their career and it's really
fascinating some of the tidbits that
people will learn is you're a bartender
you lost your job you were living on the
street i mean mark you slept on a couch
with six people no
power
no car no electricity
um all these fun things because you look
at mark and you say oh he owns the
mavericks he's the ford 400 he's on
shark tank but every single person
shares the same exact qualities they've
all had
huge challenges
and one of the messages we got to push
through them no matter what we cannot
give up we have to persevere and and one
of the messages is you know you're
looking at something what are the odds
one in a million one in a hundred
million and as uh sharon stone said on
on our podcast and this has been a a
common theme what do you have to lose
nothing
you you're here
and then you want to go here
why won't you at least give it a shot
and then we talk about some other things
making a plan and we think about what
are the successful traits that got you
there work ethic is always number one
so you it is directly proportional to
how successful you'll be and whatever
you do it's true in our personal lives
but it's also true in our professional
life then they talk about
attitude and we we talk about that at my
company's to complaining is a cancer no
one wants to hear about it
walk into the room just just the most
commonly asked question in the world how
are you most people will get that wrong
i'm good good as the 3.0
is a 3.0 going to succeed i'm very good
that's a 3.3 you really want to take a
3.3 do you want to be a 3.7
a minus no you want to be a 4.0 but why
stop at a 4.0 why not say
i'm excellent today i'm fantastic i
could be better my day is phenomenal i'm
verging on superb and just think about
the reaction
to somebody i'm good versus i'm
outstanding i couldn't be better just
just the minute you walk into a room so
you talk about attitude you talk about
teamwork the ability to get along and
motivate and inspire people
um
it's it's it's about
being true to yourself having integrity
i think these things are are really the
common thing but really
hard work pushing through the challenges
attitude there's nothing i can't do
and really i've heard you talk about the
fear of failure
okay and
everyone fears failure i've had some
success in my life in the venture
capital side you know it's sexy people
want to work in the business seven to
eight out of ten companies go bankrupt
this isn't a uh
real estate deal where you have land
it's it's it it's nothing uh but but we
really want to focus on
um
uh persevering and pushing through and
coming through the other end no matter
what and and fear is a great uh
failure is a great fear it motivates
everyone it motivates me today i have a
lot of new things that i'm uh doing but
i'm gonna try my hardest
and fear is motivating me i don't want
to fail for my personal self i'm true to
myself not i don't care what people
think
about me i care about being true to
myself and giving my all
i was on a call uh with someone on my
team on monday and i asked him hey evan
how you doing this guy manages a lot of
my youtube uh the key member of my
youtube team and he said i'm superb
like that's awesome superb i mean what a
great way to start the conversation
instead of just to your point you know
i'm good and and what i love with you
when sharing all these stories and
taking the time to go deeper with them
is realizing that listen a lot of
people's heroes
started with less than what you've got
right now
you can look at cuban right and see i
mean yeah sleep on the couch and being
far from his first job uh because he
went to close the sale instead of
opening the computer shop and but people
start with like way way way less like
you guys have the internet right now
compared to a lot of these people who
started with with less than what you've
got and if they can do it you can too
back to your point at the beginning it's
like hey i think everything is possible
um and so like showcasing those stories
and going beyond just the surface level
i think is critical um who are some of
your heroes right now
i mean my grandmother's my biggest
uh hero she's going to be 104 years old
in november hopefully she'll make it wow
she was raised in foster care you know
her parents dropped her off on a street
corner in detroit with the clothes on
her back when she was six years old
a church took her in she bounced around
foster care in a foster care home they
treated her like a servant she slept in
a closet it was
you know she swept the floors prepared
the food and she's a survivor breast
cancer uh survivor 40 years ago and
she's the major arc of our family she's
incredible
um
it's she she's number one um and so
uh
she is my hero she knows it she's my
best friend and uh
love her to death
so so if uh if grandma kaplan was to
give a final message for the audience
here what do you think she would say
what would she say she'd say
um i'm proud of the difference you're
making in people's lives
she's very proud of me
i love it and what would her message be
to the audience
she's had a rough life i mean
we'd be here a long time
evan if if i told you all the things
that she'd been through but but the
secret to
her life has been the love around her
of the people in her life
um she gave a uh speech at her 100th
birthday priority surprise birthday
party um and someone asked her what's
the secret she said that was the secret
so surround yourself with people who
love you and if you're unfortunate and
don't have those people
there are people out there like that who
will love you you can go find them i
promise you
um go seek people out go see good people
go to local
charities local things um you'll you'll
find great people but surround yourself
with people who love and who believe in
you
and and i think that's i i think that's
the main message
i love it well the man is randy kaplan
this show is called in search of
excellence youtube will link that up in
the description go check him out randy
appreciate you spending time and thank
you for
everything you're creating man it it's
really valuable and important well
appreciate you
thank you and i love the work you're
doing you do phenomenal work and i've
helped a ton of people as well so kudos
to you as well
i love it much love man we'll talk to
you soon talk to you later cheers to see
my recent one-on-one with tony robbins
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there there is a
regenerative revolution that's happening
in medicine right now in precision
medicine billionaires know about it but
the average person doesn't what pushed
me over the edge recently is i had some
experiences that really hit me hard